est ce que vous croyez pas ivan levaï
quand même que la promiscuité des grands
c'est à dire la fréquentation que vous
aviez de mitterrand vous a amené
certaines fois avoir un jugement -
objectif que celui qu'on était en droit
d'attendre de quelqu'un d'aussi écouté
que vous non moi j'ai pas peur de la
connivence des journalistes et des
hommes politiques
il ya une chose que je redoute c'est la
malhonnêteté
or il ya des hommes politiques qui sont
malhonnêtes avec des journalistes des
journalistes qui sont malhonnêtes avec
des hommes politiques
voilà surtout chacun chez soi lui il est
élu vous vous ne l'êtes pas et on ne se
noient rien moi je ne dois rien l'invité
à la che comme c'est tout ça vous amener
pas être plus sympas avec mitterrand qui
vous n'aviez pas été invité non ça
permet de voir ce qu'il y a ceux qui
demeurent d'humanité vrai chez les
hommes que vous rencontrez je fume